foreign
next up we have Luke calling from
Indianapolis Indiana hey Luke welcome to
the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call hey
thanks for calling how can we help
um so I feel like my um my budget like
my margins each month um I'm not quite
achieving any of my goals I'm trying to
be as aggressive with
as I can with my student loan repayments
but I also have a couple other things
I'm saving for
um my truck has not been super
dependable so I'm saving to replace that
and then I'm also getting married
um next year so I'm kind of saving for
those expenses and moving out and stuff
and so I'm looking at my account each
month and I'm not really getting
anywhere because I feel like I'm
spreading it all too thin so maybe you
guys could help me prioritize
yeah well congrats on getting engaged
that's exciting you've got some cool
things on the horizon so how much debt
do you have
uh right now I have about 19 000 Poland
student loans all right what's your
income
uh about 50 000. all right and when
you're you're doing your monthly budget
it do you think it's a spending problem
is it because you're saving toward the
car and the wedding where do you think
the problem lies
is it an income probably
it could mean an income problem I'm not
spending anything and part of it could
be maybe it's maybe it's not necessary
to save as much as I think like for the
car and for the wedding but
um
like I'm saving pretty much 50 of my
income goes towards my debt so I live
off of the rest and you know I'm saving
about I don't know four or five hundred
dollars a month
and I guess I'm just not sure should I
make less aggressive payments on my debt
and save just kind of for the season or
how is this truck on its last leg
you're saying you're trying to replace
your car
it's it's hard to say it's I've had to
take it to the shop pretty much every
month nothing major but 150 here 300
here and that and that's also kind of
slowing down by my savings what do you
do for a living
I'm a teacher a teacher okay and are you
doing any sort of side hustle or
anything to make additional income
um I'm not the primary reason is um I
teach band and so I have a lot of after
school commitments
um a lot of extracurricular activities
um so I don't exactly have a normal
teacher schedule yeah no band can get
pretty intense
um what about off seasons do you have
you know Seasons where you're not you
know having after school hours with the
band
yeah my summers are definitely
um available I've I've worked over the
summers in the past and been able to
make you know three or four thousand
dollars in in a month or two like June
and July yeah I think I mean right now I
love that you're taking 50 of your
income and throwing it towards the debt
I think right now it's just that season
where it's a challenge you gotta be
gazelle intense you got to kind of go
through the slog this is the not fun
part of it but you know it's gonna get
you to a spot where once that nineteen
thousand dollars is out of your life
once that debt is gone that money is
going to be able to really go towards
savings and you're going to see a lot of
progress I know it's frustrating right
now because you don't see that savings
progress you're going oh man
um but it's gonna it's gonna get there I
think it's just kind of one of those
Seasons where you got to stay the course
and keep pushing through do you know how
much you are having to pay for this
wedding have you guys talked about with
the families who's paying what you have
a clear number
yeah so
um
the family is able to contribute pretty
much everything for the wedding
um I'm paying for the honeymoon and then
I'm also wanting to save some money just
for like
the first month rent and you know the
deposit and I have no furniture so I
live at home right now so I mean I'll be
moving out for the first time so I've
also been saving a little bit for that
awesome well it sounds like you're doing
all the right things I'd get a clear
number of what I'm gonna need for all
those wedding expenses if that's four
thousand dollars for a honeymoon plus
plus then we backtrack that out and go
all right every month I need to save 400
to have forty eight hundred dollars 12
months from that one so you start to do
that kind of math and that gives you
your goal if that means I need to side
hustle then go get you a side hustle for
a season yeah and I think that's just
important to remember that it is for a
season you know you're coming up on that
marriage and it's gonna feel so good to
do it debt free and to be really seeing
that traction with your wife as you're
able to throw that money into savings